in a famous Japanese High School several
students get murdered mysteriously the
police suspect it's an intruder but the
real murderer is one of the employees
during a regular teachers meeting the
principal mentions his concern towards a
firste class which is having
surprisingly good grades all of a sudden
the principal thinks they are cheating
and asks the teachers to suggest how
they should solve this issue an young
efficient teacher named SEI hasumi
suspects that the students are using
cell phones another teacher suggests
that they should ban cell phones but
this can't stop students from secretly
bringing the body searches will be a
humiliation to students so that's not an
option here hasumi has another idea but
he needs Mr tsui's help as he's the
radio club adviser they can use the
school radio to jam the phone signals
during exams it is illegal but they will
make sure it only affects the premises
of the school and only during specific
times the principal is doubtful about
that but a few teachers admire jum's
plan jumi has always been a prominent
figure in School all teachers and
students love him equally the female
students are especially close to him
because of his friendly nature and
handsome face there's never been a
complaint about hasumi from the parents
until today an introverted student named
Reena has been absent for days and her
father claims that Reena is bullied at
school jumi rejects that as he
personally talked with each student but
none of them have noticed anything
regarding this issue hasumi requests the
father to calm down and try to solve
this issue with patience hasumi has
always been polite and sensible like
this so the students feel comfortable to
share their problems with him during the
recess two female students meet hasumi
to talk about a sensitive issue they
have seen the sports teacher Mr
shibahara being suspicious around a
student named Mia on hearing this hasumi
immediately contacts Mia and asks her
what's the whole story Mia feels
reluctant at first but jum's warm nature
allows her to speak up she had once
stolen something from a store and Mr
shibahara recorded the incident he
blackmailed her into doing indecent acts
with him or he will show the video to
everyone jumi takes Mia to the store and
helps her to apologize to the owner
afterwards he advises her not to get
worried or afraid of Mr shibahara as the
charges of sexual assault is way more
than stealing something from a store Mia
feels safe now and can finally continue
living peacefully the next morning at
school the teacher announces that the
cell phones will be collected during all
the further tests kuk the one who is
behind the cheating scheme lies that he
forgot his phone at home he pulls it out
during the test but gets shocked to see
that there's no signal kesuke gets
beaten up by the students whom he
promised to help during the test now he
wants to get to the depth of this matter
he believes that it's done by Mr Tsai as
he is always being a weird and strict
teacher and also has access to radio
club as kuki turns around he sees that
Mr turai is standing right behind him he
has listened to everything and claims
that he is not the one who had jammed
the signals however kuk still suspects
him as Mr tsuri has always been an
introvert and loves doing research on
dark topics like murders and suicide
cases the next day all students gather
in the nurse room to learn about first
aid when the students start making
Jokers the the nury tells them there's a
voice recorder in this room to collect
data so they all should mind their
speech meanwhile reena's father visits
the school again and brings some proof
he tells hasumi about a social media
board created by the students there's a
boy named tanuma who wrote negative
comments about Reena however hasumi says
that it's not a big deal tanuma is an
aggressive boy so if he took out his
anger on a random social media page
Reena should just stay away from
interacting with it the father gets
angry at not getting any operation and
leaves in a hurry hasumi proceeds
towards his class but Mia stops him in
the way she wants to share something
personal so they head to the roof
without saying a word Mia gets closer to
kiss hasumi his kind and warm Nature has
made her fall head over heels in love
with him Mia apologizes for being so
reckless but hasumi pulls her back to
kiss confirming that he likes her too
suddenly they hear someone nearby and
Mia leaves in a hurry fortunately no one
saw them kissing the next day jumi
receives shocking news reena's father
has died he used to keep water bottles
around his house to stop the cats but
someone replaced them with kerosene
bottles a fire initiated by a cigarette
Bud thrown by reena's Father which
burned him to death at least Reena is
safe as she wasn't home at that time a
detective visits the school to interview
a few teachers regarding this case Mr
Tsai stops the detective at the door and
tells him that hasumi is reena's Home
Room teacher and he used to teach at
kahara Municipal High School the
detective doesn't understand what it
means but sui leaves without saying
another word ques hears this
conversation and gets more curious about
what Mr tuuri is planning beside him
another teacher named Mr Kum is also
involved in suspicious activity and
frequently meets a naive boy named
masahiko outside the school jumi somehow
finds out that Mr Kum is having a secret
affair with masahiko he confronts Mr Kum
but doesn't plan to expose him as
masahiko is too sensitive to handle such
a situation hasumi just wants to get
something in exchange for keeping his
mouth shut Mr Kumi agrees to the deal
and lets hasumi stay at his luxury
apartment whenever ever he wants jumi
uses this chance to spend time with Mia
and their relationship gets deeper
before leaving the apartment hasumi asks
Mia to give him the password to the
students social media board meanwhile
kuk is still researching his queries and
he has found something interesting about
kahara Municipal High School while
hasumi was teaching there four students
committed suicide without any apparent
reason kuki shares this information with
his closest friends Reika and yuichiro
and asks what they think why will Mr
tsuri share this information with the
detective all of a sudden raika is
having bad vibes and advises kuk to stay
out of this matter they all get back to
the class but witness tanuma fighting
with another student someone used the
student board to accuse tanuma of
murdering reena's father by replacing
the water bottles one of the students
calls hasumi and he helps tatan Numa
calm down he wants to help tatan Numa in
coming over his anger issues and offers
to get him a drink after school for the
next few days tatan Numa is nowhere to
be seen and people say he ran away from
his house to save himself from getting
charged for reena's father's murder the
these rumors are making kesuke more
tense and he finally decides to talk
with Mr tsuri the teacher tells him that
hasumi might seem glittering all the
time but there's something really
strange about him just after a few
months of jum's joining Mr tsuri got
suspicious and started to research his
background it had strange gaps jum's
father was a doctor and he was born in
Tokyo but after middle school he
suddenly shifted to Kyoto and got
admitted into a law school but he left
the course in between and went abroad to
Harvard he got an MBA degree and worked
in a European Investment Bank but just
after 2 years he came back to Japan and
shifted his profession to teaching while
he was at kahara Municipal High School
four suicides happened Mr tsuri dug in
deeper and found out that jum's parents
were stabbed to death by an intruder
when he was 14 he was also injured at
the back but survived but a few days
before this incident jum's Home Room
teacher was killed in a car accident why
did so many deaths keep happening around
hasumi he must have some link little
does Mr tsuri knows hasumi is more
dangerous than he can ever imagine he is
a devil in Angel's clothes while he was
just 14 he killed two men including his
Home Room teacher when his parents found
out he mercilessly stabbed them to death
and injured himself to act innocent
reena's father was killed by him too as
he tried to threaten aumi which
triggered his dark hobby moreover harumi
has installed recording devices and
several power plugs in the school he has
been listening to all the conversation
between Mr tarai and kuk and plans to
get rid of both of them he follows Mr
tsuri to the local train when he notices
there's no passengers around hasumi
kills Mr Suri and hangs him down to make
others believe that Mr tsuri committed
suicide the next day at school the
principal gathers all the teachers and
students to share this unfortunate news
hearing this kuk is immediately reminded
of his last day conversation he rushed
to the classroom they talked in and he
started looking for the recording device
hasumi follows him and admires his
intelligence another student comes
looking for ques but hasumi says he
hasn't seen him but ques is right there
lying unconscious behind the rostrom
once all the classes are over hasumi
takes ques to the science lab he grabs a
soering iron and tortures ques to accept
that he was the leader of the cheating
gang he also confirms the names of other
students involved in this act as the
last question harumi asks if kesuke has
told anyone about him and kuki says he
didn't harumi feels at ease and kills
kesuke to get rid of the last witness of
his acts while he was at Howard he met a
crazy guy who enjoyed killing people and
playing with their organs he offered
harumi to be his partner as they both
have the same hobby killing others he
also teaches harumi to used several
weapons and techniques harumi is a
person with no feelings so he wasn't
loyal with his partner either once they
had killed too many people harumi put on
all the blame on his partner and burned
him alive when he started his job at the
European Bank he killed a person there
as well there wasn't much evidence
against him but he got banned from
entering the country that's why he
returned to Japan but never left his
hobby he still suffers from nightmares
about his past and tries to distract
himself by spending time with Mia while
he goes to shower Mia checks his bag and
finds tatan numa's cell phone hasumi
also took the student board password
from her which has made Mia suspicious
of him instead of discussing with anyone
else Mia innocently asks hasumi about
her queries he doesn't say much for now
but he will not take the risk of letting
Mia go he writes a suicide letter in
which he mentions about the store
incident and Mr shibahara is
blackmailing then he gets ready to kill
Mia and make it look like a suicide
several students are staying at the
school tonight to prepare for an
upcoming Festival they all are busy
decorating their classrooms according to
the given themes Reena has recovered
from the sorrow for her father's death
and also reaches the school after
greeting the students jumi gets ready to
complete his task he calls M to the roof
and throws her down after leaving the
suicide letter behind one of Mia's
friends followed her to the roof which
ruins jumi plan he killed that girl as
well without thinking but now he must
find a way to hide his crimes he calls
Mr kou and asks him to reach the school
immediately as masahiko is in danger Mr
Kum tries calling masahiko but hasumi
has blocked all the signal sign in
school when he arrives jumi kills him
immediately then he takes off Mr kum's
shoes and wears them he brings his
shotgun and kills a few students due to
the loud music other students don't hear
the sound of gunfire but then the sound
keeps repeating one of the students
finally shuts down the music suddenly
they hear hazumi speaking on the radio
he tells students that an intruder has
broken into the school with a shotgun he
advises all the students to stay
together and reach the roof to wait for
help some of them prefer staying back at
the music room while others Rush towards
the the roof but when the students reach
there they find the door locked
meanwhile a few other students decide
not to trust jumi and try using the
landlines in the staff room to call the
police one of the boys named kakaro
grabs a bow and arrow as a weapon and
proceeds towards the staff room along
with a few other students unfortunately
jumi has cut off the landline as well he
reaches the staff room and starts
shooting all the students he plans to
kill all the witnesses and climb to the
roof the students get happy to see him
and ask for his help jumi doesn't reply
and wears a protect suit to avoid blood
stains he shoots at the students and
makes sure all of them are dead then he
walks around the school to find the
remaining ones only kakeru manages to
get out of the school and asks a passer
by to call the police suddenly he
remembers about his lover satomi and
turns back to rescue her meanwhile
satomi is locked in the music room with
the remaining students she is worried
for kakeru and decides to get to the
ground floor using the Rope she faces a
rough landing and injures her leg she
drags herself to meet kakeru who is also
running towards her hasumi hears them
and a at them through the window kakeru
shoots an arrow but misses the shot and
gets killed by jumi who kills satomi as
well then he grabs the hanging rope to
reach the music room and kills the
students there as well only Raa and uiro
are left they decide to use emergency
escape shoot but hasumi notices them and
shoots them several times however Reiko
and uiro had thrown dead bodies wearing
their uniforms hasumi kills the last
student masao and injures himself to act
as a victim when the police arrives he
says that Mr kum's relationship was
exposed and in Anger he killed all the
students before committing suicide
little does he knows raika and uturo are
alive they bring the recording device
from the nurse room and it's enough to
prove jumi guilty he gets arrested by
police but says that God told him to
kill the demons in school he hasn't went
crazy but pretending to be to deceive
the police in court but he still doesn't
know that Mia also survived and yearning
for Revenge